hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a 2015 science fiction live
action movie called assassination
classroom
this movie has a very unique concept
about the relationship between students
and teacher and also has a very deep
moral story behind it make sure to watch
it till the end to find out
the movie begins with a giant explosion
that destroys seventy percent of the
moon giving its permanent crescent moon
fixture
back on earth the japanese's military
attempts to launch an attack on a
mysterious creature but unfortunately
all of the soldiers are wiped out by an
octopus lookalike monster the monster
itself is suspected to be the culprit
behind the destruction of the moon and
plans to destroy earth as well
at kunigioka junior high one of
prestigious private schools in tokyo
students especially who are currently in
their third years are required to excel
in all the fields of their education or
they will get transferred to a remedial
class called class 3e
students at class 3u will study at a
separate building which is located about
one kilometer away from the main school
building
surprisingly the same monster with a
yellow rounded face who is responsible
for the moon destruction and plans to do
the same to earth by march next year is
going to be the teacher for the class 3e
students
tatomi karasima representative from the
ministry of defence explains that the
monster's speed is unmatched and urges
the students from the class to kill the
weird creature before next year the
creature also adds that he has made an
agreement with the government to teach
at class 3e in order to delay his plan
to destroy the earth
in order to kill him the students have
to use specially made bullets and
weapons from the ministry of defense
which are harmless to humans but deadly
to the yellow creature before he leaves
kurasama mentions that the reward for a
successful assassination will be 10
billion yen which made all students
encouraged in order to assist the
students arena a highly skilled assassin
is also hired to kill the creature but
she fails
since then arena also does a part-time
job to become their english teacher
after that the class is officially named
assassination classroom
nagisa is the main protagonist of the
movie
despite his passive and shy personality
he is a very observant person he tends
to pay strict attention to his new
teacher in order to understand his
motives and compiles all the information
in his notes for reference
the first attempt of killing happens
when the yellow creature is teaching at
the class
equipped with knife and bombs installed
on nagisa he approaches his teacher to
submit his assignment and suddenly his
friend detonates the bombs almost
killing nagisa himself but unfortunately
the plan fails as the teacher manages to
dodge the explosion
not only that the failed attempt also
makes the teacher angry as it almost
kills one of his students
he threatens to kill all the students
relatives if they redo such silly things
again
since the creature seems to be
unkillable and he is also a teacher the
class decides to name him cora sensei
despite being full aware that he is the
main target of the assassination koro
sensei is able to bond with class 3 who
in turn regard him as their
indispensable teacher
throughout the school term karma akabane
who previously was a student from a
class and has recently come out of his
suspension due to protecting former
class iii e student from being bullied
joins the class he is a very smart
student as he manages to trick koro
sensei when he meets him for the first
time despite his academic excellence
karma seems to be arrogant and
overconfident cora sensei then tries to
fix his bad attitude in several ways
after school parma and nagisa are
approached by cora sensei
karma asks whether the teacher would
risk his life to protect one of his
students and challenge him to do so but
it is actually his plan to put koro
sensei at his weak spot and then try to
kill him karma suddenly jumps off the
hill while pointing his gun to the
teacher but somehow koro sensei manages
to rescue his student thanks to his very
elastic unlimited tentacles even though
his plan fails karma doesn't give up and
tells the creature that he will kill him
someday
because karasuma's strategy shows no
progress his supervisor decides to
deploy a transfer student to the class
3e in order to kill the creature it's an
ai installed in a box called ritsu ritsu
was programmed to only aim at koro
sensei and is equipped with a lot of
advanced military weapons but the
teacher manages to dodge all the bullets
the arrival of ritsu makes students
uncomfortable because it keeps firing
while class is being conducted the
students even have to pick up the
bullets later because of that the
students decide to lock her with duct
tape and chain
one day cora sensei approaches ritsu and
gives it some advice which is to
encourage it to collaborate with other
students
cora sensei then gives ritsu some data
for the ai to learn
the next day ritsu can now express some
expressions
she also creates a phone application in
order to deepen her friendship with the
students when the class is about to
start out of nowhere a strange kid named
datona breaks into the classroom he
claims himself to be stronger than cora
sensei and challenges him to duel after
class
it turns out that atono also has
tentacles as his main weapon
seeing the tentacles poro sensei becomes
very angry as he asks atona where did
the tentacles come from
but itona ignores cora sensei and
continues to attack
he almost kills cora sensei and gets
koro sensei cornered but cora sensei
manages to beat the kid with the same
weapon the students use and throw him
out of the class
etona then is carried away from the
school by his white cloak guardian after
losing the match
after school poro sensei is asked by his
students about his real intention to
teach the class
he replies that he does that to fulfill
a promise he made to someone to get
closer to his students cora sensei
conducts assassination training camp
where he uses his mock speed to teach
each student separately with targeted
revisions for their worst subjects
one night cora sensei sneaks into the
girl's room and is forced by the female
students to share his love life stories
but he then avoids the question and runs
away
a few moments later karossima's role is
replaced by takaoka an experienced drill
inspector focused on pe because he is
not making progress at all in the
assassination mission
at first takoka seems to be very
cheerful and put a lot of attention
towards his students but arena manages
to dig deeper into takoka's background
and figures out that he is a very
violent person the real takaoka is
displayed when he does physical abuse to
one of his students
karasama manages to prevent him from
doing something worse to the students
instead takoka challenges one of the
students to duel kurosuma sees the
assassination talent within the gisa and
asks him to battle with the root
instructor
with calmness and an unpredictable move
he manages to bring takoka down
because nagisa wins the instructor has
to leave the school with shame
the next day one of the students okuda
gives koro sensei a poison which turns
out later to be sodium hydroxide and
asks him to drink it instead of killing
him the poison just boosts koro sensei's
power because it stimulates his cells
cora sensei then continues his lesson
but suddenly the students ask him why
they need to study if they can get 10
billion yen by killing him after that
koro sensei gathers all his students
including arena and karassima at the
field to motivate them
he explains that a confident assassin
will always have a backup plan they can
rely on
this backup means the lesson that the
students learn for the future they will
have if they're not the one that kills
cora sensei
cora sensei also shows off his ability
to steal military stuff telling the
students that they have to excel in
everything in order to be magnificent
assassins and kill him
final exam is coming soon and to
motivate his students to gain excellent
marks for a sensei promises that the top
students of five academic subjects will
be awarded a chance to cut off his
tentacles which will greatly slow him
down meaning that the possibility of
assassinating him increases
since then with his mock speed ability
cora sensei gives his students a
first-hand experience of learning by
bringing them to places where they can
learn certain subjects directly
the result of the final exam is
announced nakamura okuda and karma
managed to get the highest marks for
english science and mathematics
also there are three more students who
manage to excel in home economics
thus the six students will have the
opportunity to destroy koro sensei's
tentacles one of the students suggests
to plan the assassination during the
summer holiday and the class agrees the
students are doing some preparations to
ensure that the assassination will be
successful with the right strategy the
execution day has come
eventually they managed to bind cora
sensei and begin the attack
thanks to negis's observation the class
manages to discover one of corosense's
weaknesses which is water and transform
the arena into a water park for the
final blow two students launch their
final shots resulting in cora sensei
suddenly exploding however koro sensei
transforms into a ball which is his
absolute form to avoid being killed
suddenly takoka and his fellows confront
class 3e claiming to be the culprit who
poisoned several students
takaoka offers to trade the antidotes
for cora sensei
nagisa and karma team up to protect cora
sensei from atona who is now working for
takoka while the other students try to
find the cure for the poison students
nagisa and karma are no match to atona's
power as they struggle to beat him
but suddenly as planned a heavy rain
occurs which weakens atona's tentacle
power in the end of the battle nagisa
manages to cut off the tentacles from
atona
unfortunately they are informed by ritsu
that takoka has kidnapped one of the
students and threatens to kill her
thanks to nagisa's intelligence they
managed to trick takoka with a fake ball
and the students managed to turn over
the table punishing takoka and his
fellows with their own weapons
at the end of the film poro sensei is
brought to the military facility
seeing that koro corosensei is
vulnerable the government proceeds to do
a public execution in front of his
grieving students before execution cora
sensei says his final words telling that
his students have shown very good
progress during the semester
however it's not that easy to kill cora
sensei he manages to survive the
execution and is allowed to continue
teaching class 3e for the second term
making class 3 the assassination
classroom again with a tone and now
enrolling permanently
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching